فمن يريد ان يساعد في الابواب مفتوحه خاصه
اكرر واقول ان المعابر يجب ان تكون مفتوحه
كافه حتى لا تكون هناك حجج للدول الاخرى
التي تقول اننا لا نستطيع ان نوصل
للمساعدات يجب ان يكون هناك تعاون كبير
يعني لك ان تتخيل ان تركيا الدوله الكبرى
العظمى المتقدمه كثيرا تستقبل
مساعدات من معظم دول العالم وعلى كافه
انواع المساعدات فما بالك في تلك المنطقه
في الشمال السوري التي تعاني اصلا من
النقص الشديد وهي بالاساس منكوبه قبل
الزلزال فهي حاجتها ماسه جدا ولكن مع
الاسف هناك من يقدم لتركيا من اجل قد تكون
مصالح اخرى واعتبارات اخرى وينسى او
يتجاهل تلك المنطقه فهذه حاجه ماسه
انسانيه يجب على الجميع ان يعمل عليها
ويجب على ان يقدم المساعدات لها ان كانوا
صادقين في ذلك فالابواب المفتوحه ومشرعه
لمن يريد ان يقدم ولمن يريد ان يساعد
واكرر واقول بانه السرعه القصوى لانه يعني
هذا الايام التي مضت في هذه الظروف الصعبه
حتى الذين نجواهم نجوا في الشارع ليس
لديهم لا ماوى ولا اكل ولا غذاء ولا دواء
ولا اسعافات اوليه ولا شيء لذلك نقول هي
كارثه كبيره وكما تعلم ان الجانب الجانب
الاخر وهذه اشاره مهمه من الحدود والتي
تتواجد فيها قوات بشار الاسد والتي ايضا
تعيق وصول المساعدات وايضا هي اعطت للعالم
انها ليست اهل وليست ثقه لوصول المساعدات
عن طريقها لانها تسيس ذلك وتستغل ذلك وكما
نسمع الاصوات من داخل
الاعلام الاس بانهم الان يقولون بان هذا
السبب هو قانون قيصر علما ان قانون قيصر
هو يستثني المواد الغذائيه والطبيه ولا
علاقه له في الحصان ولكنهم يعتقدونها
الشماعه التي يعلقون عليها فشلهم وسرقاتهم
مع الاسف الشديد